so ever since even before ant-man and
the wasp came out we've known from
Marvel Studios that the quantum realm is
going to play a huge part in Avengers 4
we weren't entirely sure what role it
would play but then ant-man and the wasp
came out and in the post-credits scene
Janet Van Dyne said time vortex
automatically start absorbing quantum
healing particles also make sure you
stay out of the tardigrade fields
they're cute but they'll eat you and
don't get sucked into a time vortex we
won't be able to save you and then it
all sort of clicked the Avengers would
use the quantum realm in Avengers 4 to
go through time not just back in time
but forward in time as well but it seems
like recently the quantum realm was
being stressed more and more and I think
we're all under estimating the huge part
that it's going to play in Avengers 4
and in the MCU moving forward I'm still
giving away copies of infinity war and
ant-man and the wasp on blu-ray and some
special edition posters all you have to
do to enter for your chance to win is be
a subscriber like the video and comment
down below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero so the actor Michael
Douglas who plays dr. Hank Pym in
ant-man and the wasp recently did an
interview with Ryan Seacrest on on Air
with Ryan Seacrest
so in this interview Michael Douglas
said that the quantum realm is the key
to Avengers 4 and the future of the
shared MCU and I'll quote him hear what
he said in the interview he said I mean
all of them I mean the quantum realm
that's the key that's the key the
quantum realm plays an important part in
all the next chapters I think of the
Marvel films I mean it's clearly the key
to Avengers for it because there's not
really much options for our heroes right
now the only way to really undo the snap
right now is to go back in time and
prevent it from happening now of course
there are other ways but this is the
most likely scenario that is going to
play out in Avengers 4 so we know that
the Avengers will use it for time travel
on Avengers 4 but will it be used for
anything else in Avengers 4 and the
interview Michael Douglas went on to say
it's a whole other world it's a whole
other language and world the Marvel
comics world you got to take a course in
it Ryan recently the director of Ant
and the wasp told us to pause the film
at a certain moment one fan took the
liberty of doing it and discovered a
whole entire city inside of the quantum
realm this opens up just tons of
different possible scenarios for the MCU
not only in Avengers 4 but moving
forward ant-man is currently stuck
inside of the quantum realm so could he
come across this city or possibly
another city that's down there and if he
does who could he possibly encounter
some people believe that at the end of
Captain Marvel she will get stuck inside
of the quantum realm somehow could
ant-man possibly run into her and that's
how Captain Marvel comes into the
picture in Avengers 4 or is there a
threat that's waiting for him down there
thanks to some leaked info we learned
about Avengers 4 there's going to be a
second villain who's a greater threat
than Thanos right now it's widely
believed to be Annihilus and in the
comics Annihilus attacks the quantum
realm with his annihilation wave so
could Ant Man possibly run into a
nihilist inside of the quantum realm and
can Annihilus possibly come out of it
and be the greater threat in Avengers 4
but the real exciting part is moving
forward in the future with a quantum
realm in the MCU the quantum realm is
connected to many heroes in the comics
but most importantly it's connected with
the Fantastic Four and Doctor Doom I'm
not saying that we're going to see any
of these characters in Avengers 4
because I don't think the Disney Fox
deal was done in time to get them in the
movie but I do think the quantum realm
is going to open up a bunch of
possibilities to introduce these
characters we know that reshoots have
been happening so there could be a
possibility for a post-credits scene but
again I doubt it but moving forward
there are going to be huge story lines
around the quantum realm involving new
characters that are returning to Marvel
so let me know what you think about this
new information that Michael Douglas
gave us in the interview that he did and
let me know how you think the quantum
realm will connect with Avengers 4 and
the future of the MCU moving forward let
me know in the comments below and don't
forget to subscribe comment and like the
video so you can enter the giveaway and
stay up to date with everything related
to Avengers 4 as always thank you all so
much for watching Wolf Wolf
[Music]